imágenes como éstas recuerdan las
emergencias ambientales que enfrenta
eeuu una mujer es rescatada en su carro
en arizona cubierto por el agua derivada
de las torrenciales lluvias que se han
presentado en los últimos días el
panorama es similar más al este del país
en kentucky donde el gobernador ha
calificado las lluvias recientes como
las peores en la historia del estado las
víctimas siguen al alza y la situación
podría empeorar
como si las cosas no fueran lo
suficientemente difíciles para la gente
de esta región ahora mismo está
lloviendo hoy existe un potencial de
tormenta severa en todas las áreas
afectadas esto simplemente no está bien
ahora es just wright mientras tanto la
comunidad se moviliza para recolectar
suministros básicos y múltiples
trabajadores recogen los escombros
las inundaciones llevaron al presidente
joe biden a declarar un desastre mayor
encanto que el viernes asignando fondos
federales al estado desastres que
oscilan entre las lluvias torrenciales y
el fuego arrasador el incendio mckinney
se expande al norte de california y pone
a prueba la capacidad de respuesta de
las autoridades consumiendo ya más de 22
mil
y algo que estamos viendo en los últimos
10 años es el rápido crecimiento de los
incendios incendios intensos que arden
en las comunidades como nunca antes
habíamos visto sin proveyendo más
mckinney es el incendio más grande de
este año en california deja ya al menos
2 muertos y no está en absoluto
contenido el estado ha sido golpeado por
dos principales conflagraciones este
2022 al sur el of fire que comenzó el 22
de julio ya controlado en un 72 por
ciento tras haber devastado unas 8000
hectáreas